dance they're mine you cannot happen
that now oh now you cannot see them ha
your face they're my doughnuts hello
everybody and welcome back to the 20th
episode of the heroin experience your
got my prestige I'm a little bit he'll
burn up to my right your left alright so
this episode Oleg we are going to be
hitting up them chickens but first off I
want to sleep because it's all like so
like a nighttime stuff like that job all
right I'm can lack one me in lag short I
really should be able to actually woke
my computer's got a poopy so that's why
I can't go online so don't wear that
will change they'll change soon all
right now we get chickens when it's it's
so see it's come with us little skeleton
cons cons cons egg noodles series hello
my name is prestige and I like to learn
video games I nope nope yep that
happened I don't dare on me all folks
what I can now fix other stuff later huh
come on okay just let's go iron I just
cover up all the dirt let me know the
stone and then well uh oh it's so
beautiful all right now we gotta find
some chickens go get some cows see no
chickens also okay so the reason that I
ended that i started this episode
somewhere different from where I ended
lapis last episode is because I tried to
implement a heroine mod that would like
bring a creature of her brain into the
game instead of just my little floater
boy oh he's cool but I want something a
little more and the mod crashed my game
of multiple times
it was like the one you get a totem and
you'll be like yo guys his totem let on
piyah an inherent attacks your favor
yeah chicken okay where do you have any
friends you have to spawn in twos at
least so you have to friend and and yet
clash my game so let's suck so I yeah oh
there's your little friend come on don't
you want to run seeds seeds and it kind
of just crushed my game a lot so I can
use that hopefully by next episode I'll
have something else come on Liz what
seeds oh that's bad poor chicken up
again oh my gosh that's good come on
come on chicken I you know what one more
one more con oh yeah heavy i asked him
down all right come on hey go I know
where's your little buddy go when I got
one I lose the other oh he sounds like
he's over you know what I out there is
could we have all the chickens back home
so hopefully yeah hopefully by next
episode we'll have like a mod that
implements him or they'll fix the other
mod and yeah i just wanna really wanted
to record since i know you guys want
this the bit you you guys have been
asking about this video some of you have
at least so uh yeah dear hope you
enjoyed and will continue come on
chickens you can do it oh I'll do that
thank you let's keep going should make a
sheep farm mix in speed of a cow farm I
don't really now this chicken here okay
whatever what I've chicken uh well I'm
losing them since I really have a
califor- day a big farm come on you know
you want the seeds you know what the
seeds
come on I want three come on there again
come on our one to know one one two
three there you go come on don't want
the seeds seeds look at these suits oh
yes the yummy oh yes let me see it's
you're not gonna follow me how the cows
gonna [ __ ] you know where I'll come back
for you through 222222 do do do those
cows are annoying so shut up you dumb
little house okay now um I'll just pull
up with dirt to do do do do do do do now
actually I all breed them at the moment
oh he's attempting to get out of here
okay look what I've seeds ng1 seeds
seeds I got you they're your mates have
loved a time look at him all years of
time okay there we go oh yeah you know
it gives the other dude she can anyone
come he he will die did you go chicken
meet your death like am I am yeah he's
dead
hmm alright we have the chicken farm
started that is good it is good can I
want to burn down these trees I'm just
kind of scared that wood burned that my
house down as well but and I will see I
should probably harvest we yell harvest
the wheat okay so that and there but
that know so that in dash I think this
yeah it's really better dupa dupa to pay
I let's harvest the wheat too so as I
said in last buddy I trying to share
this around with your friends get it
widely known since the better these
videos do the quicker I will come out
with them yeah so like oh I won't come
out with any of you guys don't get a
certain amount of use but I get like its
something getting more traffic and it
gives me more motivation to do it but
you recently posted a video about the
call of duty DLC come out and that got
like 75 views in a day which is more
than my usual videos so that gives me
more incentive to do news videos about
like tall duty and stuff so you guys
should get on get on sharing them with
sharing this with your friends I'm just
going to go no line dude Papapa exciting
quitting gameplay also if you guys have
any suggestions of games i can play
other than like Minecraft and call of
duty since I will also be a I will also
be posting battlefield but that's not
out I'm not really probably I can pose
much of a field three you're just going
to be posting battlefield 4 when it does
come out so if you guys have like
suggestions and tell me if it's a game
that I like no oven a notes gotta give a
view I'll try it out or like say a free
game for your indie game will try that
out and it's good i like it will play it
more so i got ya sir just game for me
there we go when a how many C's we got
hopefully another stack after this one
this one is going pretty far I wouldn't
be surprised if we didn't yes another
stack ha is that our final status was
your phone sec are we I can turn a
bunches we unsec throw that in there no
youyou you come down here I don't know
really what I'm doing up here oh yeah
though there's one guy in my comments
telling me he kept telling me to start a
care farmer I'm like I don't think I
have any carrots and I do I have a
single carrot so I'll start a care pharm
I'm just a lightweight and that with
that one spot that I haven't used yes
perfection perfection so to that one guy
I apologize for not really realizing I
had to carry sooner if you are still
watching this series then boom start a
carrot farm and because we'll really
only have 10 spend a lot of my bones
I'll spend all these bones and bone meal
in growing the carrier farm some will
need more space but for knowledge is to
this all right there we go and then we
just like break open this plot opt out I
did look a little more than I was
planning to but it's okay 12 that I took
the tub 05 this cat farm is going fast
yeah I remember because carrots grow I
was talking with one of my friends about
this carrots are so much more like
productive and we in terms of food
yielding since like one care supplies to
and the loaf of bread which is three
wheat is two and a half just like
character totally better than wheat
except we is good for like animals yeah
feed animals a micro an automatic
harvester
be more efficient in saying this thing
is kind of cool but be more more
officiants all right I think this is
gonna be a little big oh no it was a
little small oh wow art and then let's
just keep going like this so we get a
big is it no why didn't it fill up with
my next thing of that I don't know
usually I think I've like inventory to
econ so usually does that but whatever
22 to 23 look at all this all all these
carrots alright like a lot of carrots so
uh let's make lots of space space for
the carrots or I think that should be
good now let's plan all of them who I
missed that hey there we go ha good oh
my god I missed you oh you only gave me
one come on bro don't be selfish don't
hold your carrots back from me i want
your kids all right and then go he until
the carrots back in there through or the
extra seeds we got right there and boom
this is the only thing boom you oh it's
also used for dyeing stuff but i'm not
going to be using for that oh also are
go in there just really good like a
diamond to be legit all right now
ultimate come on the night hands so let
us sleep the slip no update available on
the cash all right guys well that is
another piggy video i got some chickens
kind of that if this was a super short
video I apologize okay I I really forgot
when I said recording this so I really
don't know how long I've been doing so I
hope you all enjoyed this if you did
leave a like ray come or subscribe and
yet as i said just share it tell your
friends since i would like this to be
known to more people
since you guys seem to really like this
and more people more the merrier so hope
you enjoyed this